Guys I have an idea to open the show today why don't we count down from 10 each of us take a number I'll start ready 10 That's the greatest idea I've ever heard 9 8 7 6 5 what are we doing 4 the worst opening ever he got a nomination 3 2 I knew it. I was gonna end on one. Yes. It's a smart list. Oh my god smart Will will will yes will look what's going on I mean you've got the headphones are over the head, but it's not hiding the great haircut you got look You know who gave me this haircut Eli the master the master of the scissors to people get I let two people cut my hair Now let me ask you something. What is Eli? Hang on. Let me finish on about talking about my
伙计们，我有个主意，今天节目开始前，我们从10开始倒数，每人报一个数，我先来，准备好了吗？10，这是我听过最棒的主意，9，8，7，6，5，我们在干嘛？4，史上最烂的开场，他获得了提名，3，2，我就知道，我本来想在1结束的，是的，这是个聪明的名单，天哪，聪明的威尔，威尔，威尔，是的，威尔，看看发生了什么，我是说你戴着耳机，但这遮不住你那很棒的发型，看，你知道是谁给我剪的这个发型吗？伊莱，剪刀大师，我只让两个人给我剪头发，现在让我问你个问题，伊莱是什么？等等，让我说完关于我的
Are you So Eli who by the way Eli's got his new my buddy, who's our buddy who's got He's got that new brush that he makes that is so gorgeous. Oh, well, let's let's plug it. What's it called? Voo, Voo, Voo deja deja Voo. I think that's what it's called. Yeah, I think yeah. Yeah, it's his Voo deja They're incredible brush. By the way, I gave those way to say I'm not even this not even an endorsement I'm just I gave them to everybody in my family all the ladies in my life My sister is my mom and everybody loves it for how is one supposed to Supposed to Google that and send Eli some money for one of these things. How do you spell Voo deja?
你是，所以伊莱，顺便说一下，伊莱有他的新，我的哥们，谁是我们的哥们，他有他制作的那种新刷子，非常漂亮，哦，好吧，让我们宣传一下，它叫什么？Voo，Voo，Voo deja deja Voo，我想是叫这个名字，是的，我想是的，是的，这是他的Voo deja，它们是不可思议的刷子，顺便说一下，我把那些送人了，这甚至不是代言，我只是把它们给了我家里所有的女士，我的姐妹，我的妈妈，每个人都喜欢它，一个人该怎么去谷歌搜索那个并给伊莱寄钱买这些东西呢？Voo deja怎么拼？
You spell it with a V. I guess. I'm kind of such a bad friend. Why don't you be a better friend? Let me ask you this. Let me ask you this when you when you take your headphones off with that brand new gorgeous haircut Will you restyle your hair? Will you just walk out the door without the with the indentation still over your head? I'm gonna He's gonna decide after it looks in the mirror. It's pretty it's pretty messy. You know what I mean? Like, I don't know. I just kind of leave it This is hard. He's googling how to spell Voo deja. I'm wasting the listener's time Listen, just take a compliment and stop slinging brushes. Okay, you look great
我想是用V拼的，我真是个糟糕的朋友，你为什么不当个更好的朋友？让我问你这个，让我问你这个，当你摘下耳机，带着那个崭新的漂亮发型时，你会重新打理头发吗？还是你会直接走出门口，头上还留着压痕？我会，他会照镜子后再决定，这看起来很乱，你知道我的意思吗？就像，我不知道，我只是随它去，这很难，他正在谷歌搜索Voo deja怎么拼，我在浪费听众的时间，听着，接受赞美，别再推销刷子了，好吧，你看起来很棒
Yeah, and I think you should continue your relationship with Eli with Eli and then the other one is Kevin wound You know Kevin my buddy in Never met him never work. No, I don't know he's tremendous. You don't talk about him. Kevin. He never talks about you That's not true Kevin. Well, why don't I mind? I gotta guess I gotta mention the guy who cuts my hair skevo Yes, hey skevo. I I've been doing this podcast for a little over a year with Sean P. Hayes. Yep I've never seen him without a hat on so Super confident about you No, you know why because it takes a long to do my fucking hair. Okay, you need a better haircut. I know
是的，我觉得你应该继续和伊莱保持联系，然后另一个是凯文·沃恩，你知道凯文吗？我的哥们，从未见过他，从未共事，不，我不认识他，他很了不起，你不谈论他，凯文，他从不谈论你，那不是真的，凯文，好吧，我为什么要在意？我得提一下给我剪头发的那个人，斯凯沃，是的，嘿，斯凯沃，我和肖恩·P·海耶斯做这个播客一年多了，是的，我从没见过他不戴帽子，所以对你很有信心，不，你知道为什么吗？因为打理我该死的头发太花时间了，好吧，你需要一个更好的发型，我知道
Vooja day. Vooja day. Vooja day. How do you spell? Vooja day? VUGA DE okay, nobody. All right, by the way, they're really good. They're really good brushes Is there a smart list discount for that? Yeah, just mention smart list and give me $10 off anything. That's not true That's not by the way. That's not true. It's not true. There is no and I know we I'm kidding Sean now you're you're the guy who cuts your hair the person who cuts your hair skevo Skevo, and he has he has the power of sight Or do you just feel his way through it? I
Vooja day，Vooja day，Vooja day，怎么拼？Vooja day？VUGA DE，好吧，没人，好吧，顺便说一下，它们真的很好，它们是非常好的刷子，SmartLess有折扣吗？是的，只要提到SmartLess，任何东西都能减10美元，那不是真的，顺便说一下，那不是真的，那不是真的，没有，我知道，我在开玩笑，肖恩，现在你是那个给你剪头发的人，给你剪头发的人是斯凯沃，斯凯沃，他有视觉能力吗？还是你只是凭感觉？我
Got I got to see him again. It doesn't it doesn't over zoom He's so charitable this shot. He wills it. He's such a nice man. You know a skevo, right? Yeah. Yeah, no No, what don't you do? You wait skevos cut your hair. Wait, what word are you saying? You keep saying skevo? Like you can't I would remember a skevo. What are you saying? That's his SK EVO skevo. Is that first or last name? It's Skevo. It's Greek. It's his first name Okay, it's Greek and he's cut your hair Jay. No, he hasn't. Yes. He has I don't think so. Yes years ago He did oh years ago. All right. Well, I believe like a couple years ago Sean I like the idea that Sean went to the guy because he said yeah, I cut I cut Jason Bateman's hair
我得再见他一次，他不会过度放大，他太慷慨了，这个镜头，他用意志力，他是个这么好的人，你认识斯凯沃，对吧？是的，是的，不，不，你没做吗？等等，斯凯沃给你剪过头发，等等，你在说什么词？你一直说斯凯沃？就像你不能，我会记得斯凯沃的，你在说什么？那是他的，SK EVO，斯凯沃，那是名字还是姓氏？是斯凯沃，是希腊语，是他的名字，好吧，是希腊语，他给你剪过头发吗，杰伊？不，他没有，是的，他剪过，我不这么认为，是的，几年前，他剪过，哦，几年前，好吧，我相信，就像几年前，肖恩，我喜欢肖恩去找那个人的主意，因为他说，是的，我给杰森·贝特曼剪过头发
Well, no because he you know he cuts is he a celebrity hair cutter He works out at a from a salon and Chris McMillan salon. Oh, okay. I love that Chris McMillan. Yeah Well, listen, I'd like to Find out what kind of guest you've got up your sleeve Willie pretty great. I hope that your guest is a little bit more interesting than us Nimrod's our guest is very interesting and has led a big life and has been a important actor and Artist for many many years
嗯，不，因为他，你知道他剪的是，他是名人理发师吗？他在克里斯·麦克米伦沙龙工作，哦，好吧，我喜欢那个克里斯·麦克米伦，是的，好吧，听着，我想找出你袖子里有什么样的嘉宾，威尔，很棒，我希望你的嘉宾比我们这些笨蛋更有趣，我们的嘉宾非常有趣，过着丰富的生活，并且是一位重要演员和艺术家，很多很多年了
Our mr. Guest is from Cleveland, Ohio originally Her mother is from one of my favorite cities Liverpool England where because as you guys know a big Liverpool supporter She started her career as a as a model and then quickly Got into the acting game to much a claim. She's got a Primetime Emmy. She's got Golden Globes. She's got a an Academy award for best actor our best actress. I don't want to get I feel like if I get if I give off too many credits I'm gonna give it away. She's incredibly talented and now she's transferring all her talents to the directing game
我们的嘉宾先生最初来自俄亥俄州克利夫兰，她的母亲来自我最喜欢的城市之一，英国利物浦，因为正如你们所知，我是利物浦的忠实支持者，她以模特身份开始职业生涯，然后很快进入演艺圈，并获得了极大的赞誉，她有黄金时段艾美奖，她有金球奖，她有奥斯卡最佳女主角奖，我不想，我觉得如果我透露太多成就，我会剧透的，她非常有才华，现在她正在将她的所有才华转移到导演领域
Her new film is bruised. That's coming out on Netflix. Oh guys. It's Halle Berry. Oh my gosh Yes, Halle Berry Hi Crazy is this so cool Hi your mother's from England and you're from Ohio. How does that work? I didn't know your mom was from England Exactly. How the fuck did that happen to me? My mom's from England, too. Not a lot of people understand that Really? Yes, where where? Shrewsbury
她的新电影是《伤痕累累》，即将在Netflix上映，哦，伙计们，是哈莉·贝瑞，天哪，是的，哈莉·贝瑞，嗨，这太酷了，嗨，你母亲来自英国，你来自俄亥俄州，那是怎么回事？我不知道你妈妈来自英国，确实，那该死的怎么发生在我身上？我妈妈也来自英国，没多少人理解这一点，真的吗？是的，在哪里？什鲁斯伯里
Shrewsbury doesn't matter. We're not here to we're not here to interview you. Not me. We're gonna talk to Halle. It's so nice to see you Did you wait speaking up since we're on that subject? Did she have A dumb question. Did she have an accent and did you grew up with that accent inside the house? She didn't have an accent really and I didn't grow up with it was a liver puddley an accent So, oh, no, I didn't grow up with that accent. No, isn't that the one is that the one where they talk about? They have different words for stairs and what man words that cockney. Yeah, cockney. Yeah Well, they say bravon talk like that. Yeah, if you're from Liverpool, you're a proper scouser is Is what you say, but but I how different would we think of you? Allie if you if you had a
什鲁斯伯里，没关系，我们不是来采访你的，不是我，我们要和哈莉谈谈，见到你真好，等等，既然我们谈到这个话题，她有口音吗？你是在那种口音的家庭里长大的吗？她真的没有口音，我也没有在利物浦口音的环境下长大，所以，哦，不，我不是在那种口音下长大的，不，那是他们谈论楼梯和什么男人词汇的那种吗？那是伦敦腔，是的，伦敦腔，是的，好吧，他们说，像那样说话，是的，如果你来自利物浦，你就是一个地道的斯考瑟人，这就是你说的，但是，如果我们认为你是什么样的，哈莉，如果你有一个
Liverpuddin accent, that would be I know a whole new thing for you. She can do it Hallie, thank you for joining us. Oh my gosh. Now look, we've only met a couple of times through our mutual friend Jeff Whom we both adore. Yes. Thank God. We have Jeff. Thank God for Jeff, right? I only have any of my money because I had Jeff I know same with me. I'd be broke if I didn't have Jeff. Jeff Wallman. Do we have any contact information? You want to give our listeners? We don't need to say Jeff Wallman, but he is one by the way, Jason You should know and I think you know this Jeff is maybe the number one fan of smart less since day one Yeah, he is a huge huge fan and his son Yale and less. They're all the whole woman family who are amazing people
利物浦口音，那对我来说将是一个全新的东西，她能做到，哈莉，谢谢你加入我们，天哪，现在看，我们只通过共同的朋友杰夫见过几次面，我们都很崇拜他，是的，感谢上帝，我们有杰夫，感谢上帝有杰夫，对吧？我只有钱是因为我有杰夫，我知道，我也是，如果我没有杰夫，我会破产的，杰夫·沃尔曼，我们有任何联系方式吗？你想给我们的听众吗？我们不需要说杰夫·沃尔曼，但他顺便说一下，杰森，你应该知道，我想你知道这一点，杰夫可能是SmartLess从第一天起的第一号粉丝，是的，他是超级超级粉丝，还有他的儿子耶鲁和莱斯，他们都是整个沃尔曼家族，他们都是了不起的人
Well, thank you to them and I just want to say I'm happy to talk to you Nimrods. I mean You have a right to rescind that by the time we're done No, this podcast is badass and I know about it because of Jeff also we talk about it So it's gonna be the worst interview you've ever had I guarantee it. I have to tell you the stupid bit that I used to do There's this burger joint in Pasadena and they sell burgers and pies and on the list on the wall You can order a raspberry pie strawberry pie whatever it is and there's a there's a berry called a lally berry And so I would say hey me and my friend would do this bit for like a half an hour Hey, what was the name of that that girl who has played Dorothy dandruff? She was so
好吧，谢谢他们，我只想说，很高兴和你们这些笨蛋交谈，我是说，在我们结束之前，你有权撤回这句话，不，这个播客很棒，我知道它也是因为杰夫，所以我们谈论它，所以这将是你经历过的最糟糕的采访，我保证，我必须告诉你我过去常做的那个愚蠢的片段，帕萨迪纳有一家汉堡店，他们卖汉堡和派，墙上的菜单上你可以点覆盆子派、草莓派什么的，有一种浆果叫拉莉浆果，所以我就会说，嘿，我和我的朋友会做这个片段半个小时，嘿，那个演多萝西·丹德里奇的女孩叫什么名字？她太
Berry and we do it for a half an hour You guys would do half an hour. Yeah, we go through all we go through all of your credits and say who was that girl? Oh, that's right. It was Yeah, you clearly got it's good clean fun Sean So Halle walk us through You're a kid from Cleveland and then you win the Academy Award for Best Actress and One of the things I love about you when you won for for Monsters ball, which was so amazing You were incredible was that you had just done not long before that Dorothy Danrich for HBO
贝瑞，我们做了半个小时，你们做了半个小时，是的，我们浏览了你所有的作品，说那个女孩是谁？哦，对了，是，你显然得到了，这是干净的乐趣，肖恩，所以哈莉，带我们了解一下，你是一个来自克利夫兰的孩子，然后你赢得了奥斯卡最佳女主角，当你为《死囚之舞》获奖时，我喜欢你的一点是，那太棒了，你太不可思议了，你在那之前不久刚拍了HBO的《多萝西·丹德里奇》
Which was a story about the first African-American woman nominated for an Academy Award? And then you become the first African-American woman to win the Academy Award for Best Actress. Yeah, how Surreal was that? Yeah That was really surreal, you know, I felt like in some way like not to get all There was there was a mission there that I was carrying out, you know, there was something that I was finishing You know, there was business that I had to sort of finish for her I always felt a kindred spirit to her in some way and probably being a little girl watching her as a kid seeing myself reflected I always saw myself in her in that strange way
那是关于第一位获得奥斯卡提名的非裔美国女性的故事，然后你成为第一位获得奥斯卡最佳女主角的非裔美国女性，是的，那有多超现实？是的，那真的很超现实，你知道，我觉得在某种程度上，不是要变得，那里有一个我正在执行的使命，你知道，有一些我正在完成的事情，你知道，我必须为她完成一些事情，我一直觉得在某种程度上与她有心灵感应，可能作为一个小女孩看着她，看到自己被反映出来，我总是以那种奇怪的方式在她的身上看到自己
So to then be the person to bring that full circle, you know I knew that it was bigger than me and it had something to do with something that I was carrying out a mission that I was on You know, I believe in destiny and that we we we have free will but some things are just destined to be I really believe that and I think that was one of those things you before that were doing Such a great job whether it was intentional or not and sort of straddling sort of commercial and artistic stuff like you know Kind of fancy things as well as stuff that sells popcorn and then you win that Academy Award. Did it kind of? Complicate your your decision process now that it was like oh well now She's not everything's got to be fancy now and and all the scripts that came in
所以成为那个让它圆满的人，你知道，我知道它比我更大，它与我正在执行的使命有关，你知道，我相信命运，我们有自由意志，但有些事情注定要发生，我真的相信这一点，我认为那是其中之一，你在那之前做得很好，无论是有意还是无意，在商业和艺术之间徘徊，就像你知道的那样，既有花哨的东西，也有卖爆米花的东西，然后你赢得了那个奥斯卡奖，它是否让你的决策过程变得复杂了，现在就像，哦，好吧，现在她不是，一切都必须是花哨的，所有进来的剧本
I bet they were all director driven and think like how did you what was the the the talking like with your team about well What should we keep the same balance should we forget popcorn like how what was that like well? Here's a funny thing Jason no scripts came in really come on come on really no really I really Was disillusioned I thought oh this the highest award of our industry is now going to garner me better opportunity Greater chances to work with all those directors, but literally nothing changed like the script truck didn't back up to my front door Why is that why because the truth is you know There was still no way for people of color like there weren't scripts written for us in that way Do you know what I mean? That was on the level of what my talent had risen to you know
我敢打赌它们都是导演驱动的，就像，你是怎么，和你的团队谈论，好吧，我们应该保持什么平衡？我们应该忘记爆米花吗？那是什么样的？好吧，这是一件有趣的事，杰森，真的没有剧本进来，得了吧，得了吧，真的没有，真的，我真的很幻灭，我想，哦，我们行业最高的奖项现在会为我赢得更好的机会，与所有那些导演合作的更大机会，但实际上什么都没变，就像剧本卡车没有倒车到我的前门，为什么？为什么？因为事实是，你知道，对于有色人种来说仍然没有办法，因为没有为我们写那样的剧本，你知道我的意思吗？那是在我的才华所达到的水平上，你知道
They just weren't out there we weren't thought of it that way and it was a hard You know coming to terms with the reality of what awards mean and awards don't mean you know So that didn't change my life one bit. I still had to work I still had what I had to go through to even direct my first movie Yeah, if I tell you like your head would blow off so I feel like you know that award Means different things for different people if you ask Nicole Kidman She might have a different reality on what that award meant for her But it didn't mean that for me, but but it didn't I didn't get offered all these wonderful scripts with these great directors
它们只是不存在，我们没有那样被考虑，这是一个艰难的，你知道，接受奖项意味着什么和不意味着什么的现实，所以那并没有改变我的生活一点点，我仍然必须工作，我仍然必须经历我必须经历的事情才能执导我的第一部电影，是的，如果我告诉你，你的头会炸掉，所以我感觉，你知道，那个奖项对不同的人意味着不同的事情，如果你问妮可·基德曼，她可能对那个奖项对她意味着什么有不同的现实，但它对我来说并不意味着那样，但我没有被提供所有这些带有伟大导演的精彩剧本
But yet I had the expectation to only do award-winning Performances how frustrating yeah frustrating because how do we even know what creates an award-winning? Role like if we all could create a fucking Oscar winning award wouldn't we all do it? Yeah, right? But you you definitely grease the rails though probably for Or more women of color to be considered for that type of Recognition yes those types of roles and even the movement that I think Followed that I could be totally wrong here. I'm not a student of movie history But you know the notion that well even though this part is written for someone who might be white or actually not even not even
但尽管如此，我还是有只做获奖表演的期望，多令人沮丧，是的，令人沮丧，因为我们怎么知道什么创造了获奖角色？如果我们都能创造一个该死的奥斯卡获奖角色，我们不都会这样做吗？是的，对吧？但你确实润滑了轨道，可能让更多的有色人种女性被考虑获得那种认可，是的，那些类型的角色，甚至我认为随之而来的运动，我在这里可能完全错了，我不是电影历史的学生，但你知道，即使这个角色是为可能是白人的人写的，或者实际上甚至不是，甚至不是
raised specific The people started thinking well, why can't we make this character of color? Why can't we just change the whole sex of this character that happens all the time? Is that true Halle? Yes, that's absolutely true. So when people you know say to me well There's never you know another black woman standing beside you winning. I say no and that while that's heartbreaking What I do know that moment change is just what you said Jason You know if you look at you know our evolution from 20 years ago into now black women are everywhere They're in all kinds of roles and like you said they're taking roles for men and changing them into women and where you know becoming more
特定的，人们开始想，好吧，为什么我们不能让这个角色成为有色人种？为什么我们不能改变这个角色的整个性别？这经常发生，那是真的吗，哈莉？是的，那绝对是真的，所以当人们，你知道，对我说，从来没有另一个黑人女性站在你身边获胜，我说不，虽然这令人心碎，但我所知道的是，那一刻改变了正如你所说的，杰森，你知道，如果你看看我们从20年前到现在的演变，黑人女性无处不在，她们在各种角色中，就像你说的，她们正在接管男性的角色并将它们变成女性，我们正在变得更加
Inclusive and we have gotten far in 20 years since that Academy award And I do think that moment Inspired so many people to think differently and to believe that you know anything was possible And if you worked hard, you know, you could achieve a goal that you had so in that way I I feel very much like it mattered Do you think with your new film and now now that you're directing in your sort of creating opportunity for yourself in the same way? You're hopefully you're gonna create a new lane for women of color to start directing themselves more and directing more films Do you do you feel do you kind of feel a burden sometimes like or not a burden?
包容，自那个奥斯卡奖以来，我们在20年里走得很远，我确实认为那一刻激励了很多人去进行不同的思考，并相信，你知道，任何事情都是可能的，如果你努力工作，你知道，你可以实现你的目标，所以在那方面，我非常觉得它很重要，你认为你的新电影，现在你正在导演，你正在以同样的方式为你自己创造机会，你希望你将为有色人种女性开辟一条新道路，让她们开始更多地导演自己，并导演更多的电影，你是否，你是否有时感到负担，或者不是负担？
But like you've got to take on that role of the person who's breaking the mold a little bit You know, I don't really feel like I have to take it on I want to take it on because I'm capable of taking it on You know and so therefore I should take it on because it's what inspires me. It's what drives me, right? So, you know, I think that as women we live in new times. We live in you know a time where You know, it's hard to really we can fight now and actually not just fight You know for not we can really make inroads today. It's not easy You know making my film was really really hard and raising money to do it and all the hoops I had to jump through but guess what I did it 20 years ago
但就像你必须承担那个打破一点模具的人的角色，你知道，我不觉得我必须承担它，我想承担它，因为我有能力承担它，你知道，所以因此我应该承担它，因为这是激励我的，这是驱动我的，对吧？所以，你知道，我认为作为女性，我们生活在新的时代，我们生活在，你知道，一个时代，你知道，很难真正，我们现在可以战斗，实际上不仅仅是战斗，你知道，为了不，我们今天真的可以取得进展，这不容易，你知道，制作我的电影真的非常非常难，筹集资金去做它，我必须跳过的所有障碍，但猜猜怎么着，我20年前做到了
I don't know if I even could have done it no matter how hard I tried and how much I wanted it I don't know if I would have been given the opportunity, you know If people would have allowed me to do it, right? Have you had the the fortunate experience of meeting younger? Girls of color that that come up to you and say, oh my gosh, you know, you did it for me You made me think it was possible and because of these stories that you're saying this 20 years It took me to get this film out there now now you've paved the way for them to hopefully make it an ounce easier Yeah, and I feel that in spades. I get that a lot and that's always really gratifying and satisfying and it reminds me that You know, I'm doing my part. I think throughout history
我不知道我是否甚至能做到，无论我多么努力，无论我多么想要它，我不知道我是否会被给予机会，你知道，如果人们允许我这样做，对吧？你是否有过遇到年轻的有色人种女孩的幸运经历，她们走到你面前说，天哪，你知道，你为我做到了，你让我认为这是可能的，因为你说的这些故事，我花了20年才把这部电影推向市场，现在你为她们铺平了道路，希望让它变得容易一点，是的，我深有体会，我经常得到那个，那总是非常令人欣慰和满足，它提醒我，你知道，我正在尽我的一份力量，我认为纵观历史
We all just carry the ball as far as we can and hopes that the younger generation picks it up and that they go even farther It's kind of like, you know what we wish for our children. We always want our children to be better smarter Yeah, you know go farther than we could it's the same idea. How have you found that? You know, I know something that will struggles with his his his looks sometimes get in the way of people taking him seriously You know, because he's distractingly handsome and you know, the shoulders back everything. It's tough It's tough. You feel like and by the way expand on that if you'd like to Haley Well, you are gorgeous. Thank you I don't know how gorgeous you were until I saw you. Oh, man
我们都只是尽可能地把球传下去，希望年轻一代能接住它，并且他们走得更远，这有点像，你知道我们为我们的孩子祈祷什么，我们总是希望我们的孩子更好、更聪明，是的，你知道，走得比我们能走的更远，这是同样的想法，你发现了什么？你知道，我知道威尔有时会因为他的外表而感到困扰，这有时会妨碍人们认真对待他，你知道，因为他帅得让人分心，你知道，肩膀向后，一切，这很难，这很难，你觉得，顺便说一下，如果你愿意，哈莉，可以展开说说，好吧，你很漂亮，谢谢，我不知道你有多漂亮，直到我见到你，哦，伙计
Don't cut her off. Haley Berry is complimenting me. Are you out of your mind? But honestly, all the advantages I'm sure that being you know, one of one of the world's great beauties can can bring you I'll bet it sometimes hurts as well when you know, you're looking to be taken seriously and and you know We've traditionally grown up like, you know with the the academics or the smart people Or whether they're supposed to have glasses on and they're supposed to be, you know, really learn it and all the but All of the knowledge that you have from the years of set experience The ease and the comfort the skill that you have to lead on a set. I'm sure is is Incredible. Do you ever get the sense that you know?
别打断她，哈莉·贝瑞在夸我，你疯了吗？但老实说，我相信作为世界上最伟大的美女之一所带来的所有优势，我敢打赌，有时当你想要被认真对待时，它也会受到伤害，你知道，我们传统上长大，就像，你知道，学术界或聪明人，或者他们应该戴眼镜，他们应该，你知道，非常博学，所有这些，但你从多年的片场经验中获得的所有知识，那种轻松和舒适，你必须在片场领导的技能，我相信是不可思议的，你有没有感觉到，你知道？
If I if I had a little pocket protector with pens in it people would listen a little bit closer Well, first of all, well, you and I don't have glasses. I don't know what that means. No, we don't Jason do you have some glasses? No, no, no, no, I don't wear glasses. I don't wear glasses. I'm young because I'm young go ahead Yeah, I you know That's true This is always a tricky question for me to answer because people say oh, it's so hard for you to be considered beautiful like poor you But at the end of the day, you know Something that is really frustrating for me people always come up to me and they say you're so beautiful
如果我有一个带笔的口袋保护器，人们会听得更仔细一点，好吧，首先，威尔，你和我没有眼镜，我不知道那意味着什么，不，我们没有，杰森，你有眼镜吗？不，不，不，不，我不戴眼镜，我不戴眼镜，我很年轻，因为我很年轻，继续，是的，你，你知道，那是真的，这对我来说总是一个棘手的问题，因为人们说，哦，被认为漂亮对你来说太难了，真可怜，但归根结底，你知道，对我来说真正令人沮丧的事情，人们总是走到我面前，他们说你太漂亮了
But you know, the truth is I long for someone to come up and say you're talented Yeah, or you're a good mother or I saw you fought for that You know Senate bill 606 to stop paparazzi from harassing kids and that was amazing You know, I wish but I always just get your beautiful and I have felt reduced by that my whole life And I have tried to fight through that and prove and I got to tell you I'm tired at 55 I'm tired of trying to prove and fight through and you know, put my intellect on display all the time and the pressure to do That I just want to be yeah trying to counter it. Don't yeah trying to counter that and yeah You know, it hasn't been a great thing in my life for people to say you're beautiful
但你知道，事实是，我渴望有人走过来，说你很有才华，是的，或者你是个好母亲，或者我看到你为那个参议院法案606而战，以阻止狗仔队骚扰孩子，那太棒了，你知道，我希望，但我总是只得到你很漂亮，我一生都觉得被那一点所削弱，我试图通过那个去战斗，去证明，我得告诉你，我55岁了，我厌倦了试图证明和战斗，你知道，一直把我的智力展示出来，以及这样做的压力，我只是想成为，是的，试图反击，别，是的，试图反击那个，是的，你知道，人们说你很漂亮，这在我的生活中并不是一件好事
I don't know what woman wouldn't want to feel beautiful, you know, so it's it's it's almost It's hard for me to even talk about it. It's a bias. Yeah, it is full of bias Yeah, if people think that if they're rich and have a lot of money, they're gonna be happy Yeah, ask anybody who's rich that doesn't make you happy the same thing if people think you're beautiful It doesn't mean you're happier that you have any you get opportunities Before the next person or that any part of your life has been made easier because you're considered beautiful It's just not true. Hallie. I get it because I'm both beautiful and rich and so that's even a double. So I I I get it
我不知道哪个女人不想感到漂亮，你知道，所以这几乎，我甚至很难谈论它，这是一种偏见，是的，它充满了偏见，是的，如果人们认为如果他们富有，有很多钱，他们就会快乐，是的，问问任何富有的人，那并不能让你快乐，同样的事情，如果人们认为你很漂亮，这并不意味着你更快乐，或者你有任何，你比下一个人获得机会，或者你生活的任何部分因为你被认为漂亮而变得更容易，那根本不是真的，哈莉，我明白了，因为我既漂亮又富有，所以那甚至是双重的，所以我，我明白了
JK JK JK, but I want I want you to hear this I hope you can hear when I say this you're so talented Yeah, and you're so good at what you do and you've been doing it at such a high level for so long Yeah, that's what I was gonna say. You can't trick anybody with that amount of longevity We know that because we're we know you're talented We know you're all those things because we are in the same industry together But I know what you mean about just people coming up off the street or whatever and they're being being very kind But yeah, they need to it's it's I don't say anything
开玩笑，开玩笑，开玩笑，但我希望，我希望你能听到这个，我希望当你听到我说这个时你能听到，你很有才华，是的，你所做的事情非常出色，而且你已经在这么高的水平上做了这么久，是的，这就是我要说的，你不能用那种长寿来欺骗任何人，我们知道这一点，因为我们，我们知道你很有才华，我们知道你所有那些事情，因为我们在一起在同一个行业，但我知道你说的关于人们从街上走过来或者什么的，他们非常友善，但是的，他们需要，它，它，我不说什么
I'd rather people not say anything than just keep objectifying me and talking about the superficial part of what I am I've been busting my butt all these years trying to meet more than that. I continue to be reduced to that I'd rather them just say nothing. Yeah one of the other admirable qualities that you have I that I love about you is that that the handful of times I've met you and just sort of hear from other people that we know in common Is what a down-to-earth grounded person you are and I think that that's a real testament to who you who you are Inside because it's not something you're born. You're always the same you are you are, you know Legitimately you in a great way and you're not you're not affected by it because it would be it's not hard as we know
我宁愿人们什么都不说，而不是一直物化我，谈论我作为表面的部分，我这些年来一直努力工作，试图达到不仅仅是那样，我继续被削弱到那种程度，我宁愿他们什么都不说，是的，你拥有的另一个令人钦佩的品质，我，我喜欢你的是，我见过你几次，只是从我们共同认识的其他人口中听到，你是一个多么脚踏实地、稳重的人，我认为这是对你内在是谁的真正证明，因为这不是你天生的，你总是同样，你是，你是，你知道，合法地你，以一种伟大的方式，你没有，你没有受到它的影响，因为它会是，它不难，正如我们所知
We all know a lot of people in this town It's not hard to be affected by all the bells and whistles and stuff and like Sean. Well, Sean is a shell He's a husk of a person You know, look at him. Yeah, I am dying to come out of it. We'll be right back and Now back to the show Wait, I have something to ask you that it's so funny. I'm here in New York and I just had some theater Are you in your other are you in your other home? Yeah, my other home to watch TV
我们都知道这个镇上的很多人，受到所有花哨的东西的影响并不难，就像肖恩，好吧，肖恩是一个空壳，他是一个人的躯壳，你知道，看看他，是的，我渴望从中走出来，我们马上回来，现在回到节目，等等，我有个问题要问你，太有趣了，我在这里在纽约，我刚看了一些戏剧，你在你的另一个，你在你的另一个家吗？是的，我的另一个家，看电视
Will says you just have a second home to watch Sean about a new house And we FaceTime and he's in there and I could see Scotty his husband in the background watching TV I said, he's like we're in our new apartment. I said just another place to watch TV So true, but we were all sitting here talking about that dress is a little bit of a depressing question and topic But we're all kind of sitting around talking about how Actors got through the pandemic and being here in New York and that the feeling is who are you as an artist when you're not doing The thing you're supposed to do so right so we had we just I just right before this podcast We just had this long discussion about
威尔说你只是有第二个家来看肖恩买的新房子，我们视频通话，他在那里，我可以看到斯科蒂，他的丈夫在背景里看电视，我说，他就像我们在我们的新公寓里，我说只是另一个看电视的地方，太真实了，但我们都坐在这里谈论那件衣服，这是一个有点令人沮丧的问题和话题，但我们都坐在一起谈论演员是如何度过大流行的，以及在纽约，感觉是当你没有做你应该做的事情时，你作为一个艺术家是谁，所以，所以我们刚刚，我刚刚，就在这个播客之前，我们刚刚进行了这个漫长的讨论，关于
Figuring out like who you are and your purpose when you're not acting and you're an actor Who are you right and so what are some of those things that fill you up? You just named a few of them, but what got you through or gets you through those waves of not working. Oh Well, since I became a mother. It's my motherhood. I mean, you know, that's the hardest job Any of us will do is be a parent, right? Yeah, so I became so Involved with my children in a whole new way when the pandemic hit because why we all had time to they were home
弄清楚你是谁，以及当你不是演员时你的目的，你是一个演员，你是谁，对吧，所以那些填补你的东西是什么？你刚刚命名了其中的几个，但什么让你度过了，或者让你度过了那些不工作的波浪，哦，好吧，自从我成为母亲，是我的母性，我是说，你知道，那是我们任何人都会做的最难的工作，就是成为父母，对吧？是的，所以我变得如此，以一种全新的方式参与到我的孩子们的生活中，当大流行来袭时，因为为什么我们都有时间，他们在家
I was home. We were all home. I became a homeschool teacher Yeah, you know they We had to find things to do within the house our creativity went to a higher level We became closer as a family my two, you know, my daughter is 13 My son is seven they actually found ways to start getting along because they had to actually talk to each other You know, they were each other's friends. What was that? I'd like to paint. I'm an artist So I had more time to draw that's great and create and right It's almost like you're forces yourself to create in new ways, right? Yeah, exactly
我在家，我们都在家，我成了家庭教师，是的，你知道，他们，我们必须在房子里找到事情做，我们的创造力达到了更高的水平，我们作为一个家庭变得更亲密，我的两个，你知道，我的女儿13岁，我的儿子7岁，他们实际上找到了开始相处的方法，因为他们必须真正地互相交谈，你知道，他们是彼此的朋友，那是什么？我想画画，我是一个艺术家，所以我有了更多的时间去画画，那太棒了，去创造和写作，这几乎就像你强迫自己以新的方式去创造，对吧？是的，完全正确
And Sean you really worked on your ability to powder and swaddle Scotty too, right? Right I think we all we all found good Jason. You met your kids during the pandemic. That was nice, right? Yeah, I've got who you got to do. It was just the one you found the second one Yeah, no, there's a nine-year-old in the bedroom next to her. Oh my oh my god There's two of them. They're so great. I was always locked. That's so I do like that idea though That you find that and and this is a theme that we have heard from a lot of people We've all talked about it too and Hallie you just touched on it that in these moments
还有肖恩，你真的致力于你的粉末和包裹斯科蒂的能力，对吧？对，我想我们都，我们都找到了好的，杰森，你在大流行期间遇到了你的孩子，那很好，对吧？是的，我有，你必须做，只是你找到的第二个，是的，不，她旁边的卧室里有一个九岁的孩子，哦，天哪，有两个，他们太棒了，我总是被锁住，那太，我确实喜欢那个主意，虽然，你发现了那个，这是一个我们从很多人那里听到的主题，我们也谈论过它，哈莉，你刚刚触及了它，在这些时刻
You got to try to find look for the positive and look for the daylight look for the things that work Yeah, focus on the things that and of course again, it goes without saying of course It was a very it's been a very dark time and a lot of people have suffered a lot There's been a lot of loss of life and so we don't mean to minimize that at all but not at all in those other moments looking for the stuff that does work and focusing on the positive stuff and I don't know but that that works for me too. I for my family wait I didn't know you did that thing about the paparazzi in the Congress. What is that? When was that and what what talked to me about that because that's such an important thing. Yeah, that was in
你必须尝试去寻找，寻找积极的一面，寻找日光，寻找有效的事情，是的，专注于那些事情，当然，再次，不用说，当然，这是一个非常，这是一个非常黑暗的时代，很多人遭受了很多，有很多生命的损失，所以我们并不是要最小化这一点，根本不是，在那些其他时刻，寻找有效的东西，专注于积极的东西，我不知道，但这对我来说也有效，我为我的家人，等等，我不知道你做了关于国会狗仔队的那件事，那是什么？那是什么时候，那是什么，跟我谈谈那个，因为那是一件如此重要的事情，是的，那是在
2013, I don't know you might not know this but I had such my daughter really had such a hard time in the early part of her life We were stalked and harassed by the paparazzi. She was so scared. She wouldn't leave the house She didn't want to leave the backyard. She didn't want to go to school She would always say she was afraid of the men out there and she would get the shivers and she would cry and you know, it was really really hard and I went through this child custody case to try to move to France because I Realized that the laws in France were different than the laws in America and the paparazzi not that they couldn't take pictures And you know and realize their amendment rights but they didn't have the right to stalk and lay and wait and chase and terrorize and
2013年，我不知道你可能不知道这一点，但我有，我的女儿在她的生命早期真的过得很艰难，我们被狗仔队跟踪和骚扰，她太害怕了，她不会离开房子，她不想离开后院，她不想去学校，她总是说她害怕外面的人，她会发抖，她会哭，你知道，这真的真的很难，我经历了这场子女监护权案，试图搬到法国，因为我意识到法国的法律与美国的法律不同，狗仔队，不是他们不能拍照，你知道，并意识到他们的修正案权利，但他们没有权利跟踪、埋伏、追逐和恐吓，以及
Come so close to you and shout obscenities and all kinds of things that they were allowed to do here in the state So I tried to move to France for a better life Got denied that so when I lost that case I thought I gotta then change the law But I thought how am I gonna do that like George Clooney had tried rat pit a try people had tried to deal with this paparazzi situation But to no avail, but it's funny how when when you absolutely have to do something for a greater purpose than yourself This was for my daughter. I saw her unraveling. I was afraid of how this would affect her You know moving forward psychologically like she was a guinea pig
离你那么近，大喊淫秽词汇和各种他们在这里被允许做的事情，所以我试图搬到法国去过更好的生活，那个案子败诉了，所以当我输了那个案子时，我想我必须改变法律，但我心想我该怎么做呢？就像乔治·克鲁尼尝试过，拉特·皮特尝试过，人们尝试过处理这个狗仔队的情况，但无济于事，但有趣的是，当你绝对必须为了比你自己更大的目的做某事时，这是为了我的女儿，我看到她崩溃了，我害怕这会如何影响她，你知道，向前看，心理上，就像她是一只豚鼠
I felt and I thought I gotta have to fix this. So I Went up to Sacramento. I met all these lobbyists raised money Paid a lot of them because that's what you have to do. I realized and I got in there and Adele came to my rescue She reached out to me a lot of my peers everybody said they hated it But when it came down to actually putting their money where their mouth was and going to Sacramento and testify Nobody wanted to go all these moms and people that said I hate this. I hate this Crickets, nobody wanted to show up other than Adele name names name while tell you the ones that did show up Assume all the other ones didn't
我感觉，我想我必须解决这个问题，所以我去了萨克拉门托，我遇到了所有这些游说者，筹集了钱，付给了他们很多人，因为这就是你必须做的，我意识到，我进去了，阿黛尔来救我，她联系了我，我的很多同龄人，每个人都说他们讨厌它，但当真正需要把钱花在刀刃上，去萨克拉门托作证时，没人想去，所有这些妈妈和说我讨厌这个、我讨厌这个的人，蟋蟀，除了阿黛尔，没人想出现，说出名字，说出名字，我会告诉你那些确实出现的人，假设所有其他人都没有
Adele showed up she wrote a hundred thousand that she called me up out of the blue I hate what you're doing. Haley. I want to give she gave me a hundred thousand dollars just for the cause And my dear friend Jennifer Gardner, she showed up and she went to testify with me and so the three of us fought this fight and Got the law change. Yeah, I do remember seeing that I just went with a powerful image to have you guys together Finding that I remember it, but I didn't remember what the result of that. Yeah, what a change from and what is it now? Yeah, what it what what it was what I just said they could lay in weight They could chase they could become very close to us. They could shout obscenities whatever
阿黛尔出现了，她写了一张十万的支票，她突然打电话给我，我讨厌你正在做的事情，哈莉，我想给，她给了我十万美元，只是为了这个事业，我亲爱的朋友詹妮弗·加纳，她出现了，她和我一起去作证，所以我们三个打了这场仗，并改变了法律，是的，我确实记得看到那个，我只是带着一个强大的形象，你们在一起，发现我记得它，但我没记住那个的结果，是的，从那以后发生了什么变化，现在是什么？是的，它是什么，我刚才说的，他们可以埋伏，他们可以追逐，他们可以变得非常接近我们，他们可以大喊淫秽词汇，无论什么
We couldn't take away their first amendment, right? Obviously, but what we argued for was if you're gonna steal these photographs At least do it in a way that the kids don't know it. They don't feel harassed and they're not terrorized So they had to be a hundred feet away They couldn't sit outside our house and every time we pulled out of the driveway They couldn't like start a convoy and follow us for our entire day. They couldn't do that anymore They couldn't after they got a photo they had to leave now right away people thought well Nobody's gonna adhere to this so it happened to me right after the you know We passed the bill the judgment was done it happened to me the very next day
我们不能剥夺他们的第一修正案权利，显然，但我们争论的是，如果你要偷这些照片，至少以一种孩子们不知道的方式做，他们不觉得被骚扰，他们没有被恐吓，所以他们必须在100英尺外，他们不能坐在我们房子外面，每次我们把车开出车道，他们不能像开始车队一样跟着我们一整天，他们不能再那样做了，他们不能在拍到照片后，他们必须马上离开，现在人们想，好吧，没人会遵守这个，所以它发生在我身上，就在我们通过法案后，判决完成了，它就在第二天发生在我身上
And that's the way the paparazzi they were testing me Are you really does this law really have legs or is this bullshit and right away that very next day? I had the police there. I was Within my rights that guy got sent to jail like so they started to realize this really does have legs But the big reason I think it had legs was people like Jessica go people that were editors of these magazines that traditionally Paid a lot of money for these children that put this high price tag on these kids head They because of this movement realized you know what it's our responsibility to take the price tag off these kids head So they stopped buying these photographs at these astronomical amounts of money
那就是狗仔队的方式，他们在测试我，你真的，这个法律真的有腿吗，还是这是胡扯，马上，就在第二天，我有警察在那里，我在我的权利范围内，那个家伙被送进了监狱，所以他们开始意识到这真的有腿，但我认为它有腿的很大原因是像杰西卡·戈这样的人，那些传统上为这些孩子支付很多钱，把高价标签贴在这些孩子头上的杂志编辑，因为这场运动，他们意识到，你知道吗，把这些孩子头上的价格标签拿掉是我们的责任，所以他们停止以这些天文数字购买这些照片
And so it sort of worked in tandem once the bill was passed the editors You know felt their humanity and some way and and a shift God that's so cool That's going Jay Sean you used to used to wait outside the paparazzi's house Yeah, and they come out and you'd go guys. I'm here You know is it just the fact that that COVID has happened and and all the the celebrities are wearing masks now that that the paparazzi has sort of gone away because I Haven't seen them waiting around the usual spots or following the usual people. I certainly I certainly don't don't get bothered whatsoever
所以它有点协同工作，一旦法案通过，编辑们，你知道，感受到了他们的人性，以某种方式，转变，天哪，那太酷了，那太酷了，杰伊，肖恩，你过去常在狗仔队的房子外面等，是的，他们出来，你会说，伙计们，我在这里，你知道，仅仅是因为新冠发生了，所有的名人都戴着口罩，所以狗仔队已经消失了吗？因为我没看到他们在通常的地方等着，或者跟着通常的人，我当然，我当然根本没有被困扰
But the the normal spots I don't see them anymore Is it does it have to do is it a combination of those things or what's your understanding of the current paparazzi health? Yeah, I think it's a combination, but I think it stopped long ago that that culture kind of died like in 2014-15 after the bill passed and the editors got on board. It's it's sort of past Oh, well, you know what Jason what you said it doesn't happen to you. It's primarily happens to women. Yeah, right exactly Primarily happens to women and children which was also agreed I noticed a big difference with with my my ex-wife Amy would have there were a lot of pictures with the kids and she Go to the grocery store or whatever and my kids had that same thing
但正常的地方，我再也看不到他们了，它与这些事情的组合有关吗，或者你对当前狗仔队健康的理解是什么？是的，我认为这是一个组合，但我认为它很久以前就停止了，那种文化在法案通过后的2014-15年左右就死了，编辑们加入了，它，它有点过去，哦，好吧，你知道吗，杰森，你说的，它不会发生在你身上，它主要发生在女性身上，是的，对吧，完全正确，主要发生在女性和儿童身上，这也是我注意到的一个很大的区别，我的前妻艾米会有，有很多和孩子的照片，她去杂货店什么的，我的孩子也有同样的事情
Which is they hated those guys would come up and get in their face and then it because of what you did and I remember when I Remember when you did that. I wanted to go with you. I was boy. I was really busy that weekend But but I will say the other thing the real thing Jason kind of to what you're saying What's shifted is a lot of this stuff has become because everybody's got a phone on them A lot of stuff has become more. I'm gonna use the term user generated So now I noticed like this summer when I was on the East Coast You go to Starbucks and even though you're wearing masks, whatever all the sudden it shows up They have these curated sites on like Instagram where they go
那就是他们讨厌那些家伙走过来，贴在他们脸上，然后因为你所做的，我记得当你做那个时，我想和你一起去，我，我那个周末真的很忙，但我会说另一件事，真正的事情，杰森，有点像你说的，改变的是很多这种东西已经变成了，因为每个人都有手机，很多东西已经变得更多，我要用用户生成这个词，所以现在我注意到，就像今年夏天我在东海岸时，你去星巴克，即使你戴着口罩，无论什么，突然它就出现了，他们在Instagram上有这些策划的网站，他们去那里
They put a picture of you like you just see some guy who notices it that it's you with your kids And they don't even fall under the paparazzi laws because they're just a regular person So they just take a photo with their phone and then they load it up And then that site has a couple hundred thousand and they're not even a professional Paparazzi, you know, whatever that means, right? They're just some person and it's very Intrusive the sneaky photos are the worst. Well, and what what also has happened to you know People put their own photos up on their own Instagram now. So right that's you know We're putting out better photos of our life and what we're doing and the paparazzi could ever get so that I think the whole culture is changing
他们放一张你的照片，就像你只是看到某个路人认出是你和你的孩子。他们甚至不受狗仔队法律的约束，因为他们只是普通人。所以他们就用手机拍张照，然后上传，那个网站就有几十万的点击量，他们甚至都不是专业的狗仔队，你知道，不管那意味着什么，对吧？他们只是普通人，这非常具有侵入性，那些偷拍的照片最糟糕了。嗯，还有发生在你身上的事，你知道，现在人们把自己的照片发到自己的Instagram上。所以没错，就是这样，我们发布了关于我们生活和我们在做什么的更好的照片，比狗仔队能拍到的要好，所以我认为整个文化正在改变。
That's no longer interesting as interesting as it used to be because people are putting their whole like they wake up in the morning And they're doing their own selfie. Well, it was the gotcha thing too, right? It was the gotcha They wanted to have the gotcha element. Yeah, which is why it was so harassing They would say things to me when my kids were around just to get a reaction out of me to get that gotcha photo Without realizing what you're saying is potentially emotionally damaging my kid You're saying things that you shouldn't be saying to a child's mother while she's in her arms, you know They they they had very little respect for for the children, which was the hard part Are you feeling that it's different now? Are you feeling? Oh for sure. Yeah, nobody follows me anywhere, and I love it
那不再像以前那么有趣了，因为人们把他们的整个生活，比如他们早上醒来，都在自拍。嗯，这也是那种“抓拍”的东西，对吧？他们想要那种“抓拍”的元素。是的，这就是为什么它那么令人骚扰。当我的孩子在身边时，他们会对我说话，只是为了让我有反应，为了得到那张“抓拍”的照片，却没意识到你所说的话可能会在情感上伤害我的孩子。你在孩子母亲抱着她的时候，对她说些你不该说的话，你知道，他们对孩子几乎没有什么尊重，这是最困难的部分。你觉得现在有什么不同吗？你感觉到了吗？哦，当然。是的，没人再跟着我了，我喜欢这样。
Wait, so so Halle so you got my life back So you got your life back and you and your life is also included like really reconnecting like a lot of us We were saying with our kids and with our life, but what do what do you do? Like what are you watching when you go home and you're just chilling at home? What is Halle Berry watching on Netflix? I need to know so bad. No, you don't. Yeah, I was gonna say that Because my daughter is obsessed with the squid game. It's like I only watch things I mean, I am a fan of Ozark. I gotta tell you but but what I'm watching right now I'm only watching since the pandemic. I used to watch what I wanted to watch before the pandemic
等等，所以哈莉，你找回了我的生活。所以你找回了你的生活，你的生活也包括像我们很多人说的那样，真正地与我们的孩子和我们的生活重新连接，但你做什么呢？当你回家，只是在家里放松时，你在看什么？哈莉·贝瑞在Netflix上看什么？我太想知道了。不，你不想。是的，我正要说，因为我女儿沉迷于《鱿鱼游戏》。我只看一些东西，我的意思是，我是《黑钱胜地》的粉丝，我必须告诉你，但我现在看的东西，我只是从疫情开始才看的。疫情之前我过去常看我想看的东西。
But when we all got stuck in the house at all times It became about what the kids wanted because they desperately needed activity. They needed something more than I need it, right? So our the culture of our house became what the kids wanted So I was watching a lot of like really, you know kids stuff like for my seven-year-old He loves like raw fam fishing because he's into fishing so we watch a lot of that My daughter the squid game. I've watched the whole thing twice now. I've seen stranger things about the whole season Wow seasons like two times now, right? You know, it's it all revolves around Are they old enough yet to understand what you do what you have done?
但当我们都被困在家里时，一切都变成了孩子们想要的东西，因为他们迫切需要活动。他们需要的东西比我需要的更多，对吧？所以我们家的文化变成了孩子们想要什么。所以我看了很多，你知道，孩子看的东西，比如我七岁的孩子，他喜欢钓鱼，因为他喜欢钓鱼，所以我们看了很多那个。我女儿看《鱿鱼游戏》。我已经把整部剧看了两遍了。我看过《怪奇物语》的整个一季。哇，两季了，对吧？你知道，这一切都围绕着……他们长到足以理解你是做什么的，你做过什么了吗？
What you aspire to do the difference between acting and directing why why mommy's working? Even after a principal photography is done. You're doing editing You're like it's going on and on and on like do they do they give it up to you? Do they recognize that what you do is is is tough complicated work? No, they could care less And they don't give it up to me for nothing when I try to get them to give it up They're just you're just regular old crackers like you're nobody mom like they're like, you know, we want to be Billy Eilish like You got to do some kid movies
你渴望做什么，表演和导演的区别，为什么妈妈在工作？即使在主体拍摄完成后，你还在剪辑。你就像，它没完没了，他们会理解你吗？他们认识到你所做的是艰苦、复杂的工作吗？不，他们才不在乎。当我试图让他们理解时，他们根本不买账。他们只是说，你只是个普通的旧饼干，你是个无名小卒妈妈，就像，你知道，我们想成为比莉·艾利什，就像，你得拍些儿童电影。
I'm telling you it's the only way to stay relevant with your kids is to like do like a bunch of animated and kid movies And then I know then they adore you. I'm begging for one of those when nobody nobody has offered that to me What about this film that you directed? Is this something for them or is door? No, is it is it adult? No It this is a hardcore tough story, right? It is it's really hardcore, but I got to tell you my daughter just saw two parts of it I Said to her, you know Because it's on Netflix I said to her Would you please come to my last watch down of my film you may never see it on the big screen?
我告诉你，与孩子们保持联系的唯一方法就是拍一堆动画片和儿童电影，然后我知道他们就会崇拜你。我一直在乞求拍一部那样的电影，但没人向我提供。那你导演的那部电影呢？这是给他们看的吗？还是……不，它是成人的吗？不，这是一个硬核、艰难的故事，对吧？它确实非常硬核，但我得告诉你，我女儿刚看了其中的两部分。我对她说，你知道，因为它在Netflix上，我对她说，你愿意来看我电影的最后一次审片吗？你可能永远不会在大银幕上看到它。
So I'd really love you to see what I did and I said it's you know, it's not totally appropriate for you you're 13 But you're my kid, so I really want you to see what I work so hard on and why I miss so much time great From being with you right so we go to do the watch down and The color is all wrong. I don't know what happened some blue green luck got put over the whole thing the Ozark button pushed So we get like so far we get to the love scene that I have with a man and that's when I realize Oh, God, the colors are wrong, but she watches the love scene and she's looking at me and she's like, oh, whoa mom really? Wow It goes like that So then my editor who's sitting next to me not really realizing my 13-year-old daughter is there it says go to the second love scene
所以我真的很想让你看看我做了什么，我说，你知道，它对你来说并不完全合适，你才13岁。但你是我的孩子，所以我真的很想让你看到我为之努力工作的东西，以及为什么我错过了那么多和你在一起的时间，对吧？所以我们去审片，颜色全错了。我不知道发生了什么，整个画面上被加上了某种蓝绿色的滤镜，就像按下了《黑钱胜地》的按钮。所以我们看到……我们看到了我和一个男人之间的爱情戏，那时我意识到，哦，天哪，颜色错了，但她看着那场爱情戏，她看着我，她说，哦，哇，妈妈，真的吗？哇，原来是这样。所以坐在我旁边的剪辑师，没意识到我13岁的女儿在那里，说，看第二场爱情戏。
And I want to see what color that is what that looks like well That's another love scene my daughter didn't know this and it's a love scene with a woman So she goes to that second love scene and then my daughter's like whoa Mom we need to have some conversations. You didn't tell me and I said Nala This is a movie like none of this is true like none of this is real and so it started You know us to have a conversation really for the first time about what I do and about playing characters And what's real and what's not real and she was asking me how do you do that? And how do you get in that mindset and how does it make you feel and because she only saw two love scenes?
我想看看那是什么颜色，看起来怎么样。嗯，那是另一场爱情戏，我女儿不知道这一点，这是一场和一个女人的爱情戏。所以他转到第二场爱情戏，然后我女儿说，哇，妈妈，我们需要谈谈。你没告诉我。我说，娜拉，这是一部电影，这一切都不是真的，这一切都不是现实。所以它开始了，你知道，我们第一次真正地谈论我做什么，谈论扮演角色，什么是真的，什么不是真的。她问我，你是怎么做到的？你是怎么进入那种心态的？它让你感觉如何？因为她只看到了两场爱情戏。
And I think you guys would all attest those are some of the hardest scenes we we do as actors They're the most awkward there. It's not always fun. It's you know, it's Yeah, so it started for the first time a real conversation with my daughter about sexuality about my work in the business And oh my god, how hard I had to fight to do the film But it was ironic that those doing and then after that my editor goes this is all wrong. We're gonna come back We're not gonna sit through this so we left so that's all my daughter saw We're just love scenes Sean, you know, you know Jason grew up in showbiz. So he and his wife when they get together
我想你们都会证明，作为演员，这些是我们做的最难的戏。它们最尴尬，并不总是很有趣。它是，你知道，是的，所以它第一次开始了我和我女儿之间关于性、关于我在这个行业的工作的真正对话。天哪，我为了拍这部电影不得不奋斗得有多辛苦。但讽刺的是，那些……然后在那之后，我的剪辑师说，这全错了。我们要回来，我们不会坐在这里看完。所以我们离开了，这就是我女儿看到的全部。只是爱情戏。肖恩，你知道，你知道杰森是在演艺圈长大的。所以他和他的妻子在一起时。
They call it love scenes like when they made their kids, baby Let's go upstairs and have a love scene. I did I did this this film at the Sunday It was in the Sundance Film Festival years and years and years ago called Billy's Hollywood screen kiss and it was this gay flick and I had to Be in bed and have this love scene with a straight guy who was playing gay But he was straight guy in real life. We're super super great guy and I kept because I'm such a caretaker I kept saying to him. I'm not attracted to you. I'm not attracted to it all I think you're ugly like don't worry about a thing
他们把爱情戏称为，当他们制造孩子时，宝贝，我们上楼去演一场爱情戏吧。我多年前在圣丹斯电影节上拍过一部电影，叫《比利的好莱坞银幕之吻》，那是一部同性恋电影，我必须躺在床上，和一个扮演同性恋的直男演这场爱情戏。但他现实生活中是个直男。我们是非常非常棒的人，我一直，因为我是一个照顾者，我一直对他说，我不被你吸引。我一点也不被你吸引。我觉得你很丑，别担心任何事。
I'm just gonna put my hands on your pants, but I really don't care. I'm not into it. Where are you attracted to him? No, I mean his personality. He's a great great human being but but not my type. I get so so square When I've directed a few sex scenes that I I'll put a pillow between the two actors when they're having to go at it So that there's no Connection that there's this this pillow barricade that I would like it if a director Push that on me when I'm having a sex scene with somebody because then you can then you can kind of like It's all completely fake then. There's actually no contact whatsoever Yeah, but at some point you got to have yet the camera has to film no
我只是要把手放在你的裤子上，但我真的不在乎。我不感兴趣。你被他吸引了吗？不，我是说他的个性。他是一个非常非常棒的人，但不是我的类型。我变得如此……死板。当我导演了几场性爱戏时，我会放一个枕头在两个演员之间，当他们不得不演的时候，这样就没有接触，有一个枕头路障。如果我在和某人演性爱戏时，导演能强加给我这个，我会很高兴，因为那样你就可以……那样就完全是假的了。实际上没有任何接触。是的，但在某个时候你必须……摄像机必须拍摄，不是吗？
But it all depends depends if there's a dip there's a blanket over you all these things are Are somewhat arbitrary and a director can decide yes or no like they can make it a lot more Comfortable and be a little bit more creative with the way in which they make it look sensual We could put a hood over you if you want Jason if you just don't look at the person either There you have no sensory pillow case. Who was that actor who said who was that actor who said in a love scene is like a famous story He said I apologize if I get hard and I apologize if I don't yeah Yeah, I don't remember who said that you know, it's so weird like like two weeks ago I was doing this I was working on this thing with with our friend with our new friend Tyka white tee tee
但这完全取决于……取决于你们身上是否有毯子，所有这些事情在某种程度上是随意的，导演可以决定是或否，就像他们可以让它更舒适，并在使它看起来感性方面更有创意一点。如果你愿意，杰森，我们可以给你套个头套，如果你也不看那个人。那里你没有任何感官枕套。是谁说那个演员在爱情戏里就像一个著名的故事？他说，如果我硬了，我道歉，如果我没硬，我也道歉。是的，我不记得是谁说的了。你知道，这太奇怪了，就像两周前我正在做这个，我和我们的朋友，我们的新朋友泰卡·怀蒂蒂一起工作。
and I was shooting this scene and Right at the end Elizabeth Moss and I are there we're celebrating and I play her boyfriend and we turn this thing and Tyka just goes you guys celebrate. You're really happy and maybe you kiss and we're rolling and Lizzie turns to me and she goes should we kiss and I go I guess and then he goes and action and we just kid like it happened Like boom boom there was no and it was very weird like very Stilted just like should we kiss yeah, sure okay, and then and you never talk about should we open our mouths? Should it just right like a passion or should we touch our tongues like that's a big one like that yeah, that's what I mean Yeah, it's never discussed and and if somebody goes for it and the other and the gates closed
我正在拍这场戏，就在最后，伊丽莎白·莫斯和我在一起，我们在庆祝，我扮演她的男朋友，我们转过身，泰卡就说，你们庆祝吧。你们真的很开心，也许你们接吻了。我们正在拍摄，莉齐转向我，她说，我们要接吻吗？我说，我想吧。然后他说，开始。我们就接吻了，就像它发生了，砰砰，没有……而且非常奇怪，非常生硬，就像，我们要接吻吗？是的，当然，好的。然后你从来不谈论，我们应该张开嘴吗？应该只是……对吧，像激情一样，还是我们应该触碰舌头？就像那是一个大问题，是的，这就是我的意思。是的，从来没有讨论过，如果一个人去做了，而另一个人的嘴闭着。
That's embarrassing and then and then so on the second so on the second take you keep your mouth closed But their gates open and it's like oh god and then it's yeah, it's really awkward Isn't that what you guys follow with the with the pillows and the sorry. I mean you have removed any kind of humanity sounds really sexy and We will be right back Alright back to the show So so howdy so what was the moment where you were like, okay? I'm gonna direct and I'm gonna direct this movie
那很尴尬，然后……然后在第二条，你保持嘴闭着，但他们的嘴张开了，就像，哦天哪，然后它……是的，真的很尴尬。你们不是用枕头和抱歉来处理吗？我的意思是，你们已经去除了任何人性。听起来真的很性感。我们马上回来。好的，回到节目。所以，哈莉，你什么时候觉得，好吧，我要导演，我要导演这部电影？
What was that oh? God, you know it wasn't really what I set out to do when I decided to do this film I was just gonna be the actor. I mean training to play an MMA fighter was largely enough You know that that was hard enough for me to do I figured so to direct and then be my debut I'd never directed before like that just seemed like not the move so I actually when I got the producers to Because it was really written for like a 21 year old white Irish Catholic girl and like Blake life was attached to it Oh, you were busy
那是什么，哦，天哪，你知道，当我决定拍这部电影时，这并不是我真正打算做的。我只是想成为演员。我的意思是，训练扮演一名综合格斗选手已经足够了。你知道，这对我来说已经够难了。我想，所以要导演，然后作为我的处女作，我以前从未导演过，就像那看起来不像是个好举动。所以我实际上，当我让制片人……因为它是为像一个21岁的白人爱尔兰天主教女孩写的，布莱克·莱弗利当时被选中了。哦，你当时很忙。
Oh Wait Blake Lively was attached initially like that was and then wow. Yeah, when I got the script She was attached. We had the same agent. I had just moved to William Morris from CAA and it was the first script They gave me and I was like thanks guys. I love this, but it belongs to somebody else. Yeah, right on That's like great agenting right and they said Yeah, but we think based on our conversations with you This is something you would really love so Let's just wait and see Blake hasn't done it this far. She may not do it. She may if she does cool
哦，等等，布莱克·莱弗利最初被选中了，就像那是……然后，哇。是的，当我拿到剧本时，她被选中了。我们有同一个经纪人。我刚从CAA搬到威廉·莫里斯，这是他们给我的第一个剧本，我说，谢谢你们。我喜欢这个，但它属于别人。是的，没错。那真是很棒的经纪工作。他们说，是的，但我们认为根据我们与你的谈话，这是你会真正喜欢的东西。所以让我们等着看吧。布莱克到目前为止还没拍。她可能不会拍。她可能……如果她拍了，酷。
But we just want to know is this the kind of thing you're looking to do and I said, yeah It is and I'm just gonna wait and I'm gonna hope that she on her own volition She passes on this which she did six months later, but in that six months I was reimagining the whole script the world I was writing it down like how the character would be different being a middle-aged black woman versus a very young 21-year-old white woman, right and how important it would be to have a how Telling a story of a woman having a last chance versus another chance how more much more impactful and meaningful that would be So I kept doing my work and six months later when she passed I went to the producer Basil Iwannick and I said hey
但我们只是想知道，这是你想要做的那种事情吗？我说，是的，确实是。我只是要等，我希望她能自愿放弃这个角色，她六个月后确实这样做了。但在那六个月里，我一直在重新构思整个剧本，这个世界。我把它写下来，比如这个角色作为一个中年黑人女性与一个非常年轻的21岁白人女性会有什么不同，对吧？以及讲述一个女人拥有最后一次机会而不是另一次机会的故事，会有多么重要，会有多么大的影响力和意义。所以我一直在做我的工作，六个月后当她放弃时，我去找制片人巴兹尔·伊万尼克，我说，嘿。
I got an idea. It should be me and here's the story. Here's the world. Here's the story and here's why it's better and he said Great. Yes, that sounds like a good thing now go find a director and I was like me find the director He said yeah, go find the director So I set out on this journey to find a director I met with 12 13 people and and I met with Established directors first-time directors But what I realized is that because this story wasn't on the page yet It was only in my head the reimagining of it that nobody got it like I got it
我有个主意。应该是我的，这是故事。这是世界。这是故事，这就是为什么它更好。他说，太棒了。是的，那听起来是件好事，现在去找个导演。我当时想，我去找导演？他说，是的，去把导演找来。所以我踏上了寻找导演的旅程。我见了12、13个人，我见了成熟的导演，第一次当导演的人。但我意识到，因为这个故事还没写在纸上，它只在我的脑海里，对它的重新构思，没有人像我一样理解它。
Nobody saw it like I saw it and I had to come to I had to come to Jesus moment where I realized If this is going to come to fruition the way I see it, I'm gonna work harder than I've ever worked physically on anything in my whole Career I have to make sure it's in the right hands and that this world Will be realized in the way that it should be realized, you know It's a it's a new world to see for a movie like this. That's a female point of view. It had to be very specific What's it called? It's called bruised. Oh bruised, right? That's right And did you do the writing on it Hallie the the change to it? I did I worked with with the original writer Michelle Rosenfarr But we worked very closely together and I totally reimagined the world and the characters and like the little boy in the movie
没有人像我一样看到它。我不得不经历一个顿悟时刻，我意识到如果这要按照我看到的方式实现，我将比我整个职业生涯中在身体上做过的任何事情都要努力。我必须确保它在正确的手中，并且这个世界将以它应该被实现的方式被实现，你知道。这是一个新的世界，可以看到像这样的电影。这是一个女性的视角。它必须非常具体。它叫什么？它叫《伤痕累累》。哦，《伤痕累累》，对吧？没错。你写了剧本吗，哈莉，关于它的改变？我做了，我和原作者米歇尔·罗森法尔一起工作。但我们合作非常紧密，我完全重新构思了世界和角色，比如电影里的小男孩。
He used to talk in a my draft. He'd now he's mute like there's so many things that we changed about it that made it very unique to this world Well, talk to me about the MMA thing what so you had to train for that and like what was that like? Oh my god Do you guys follow MMA at all? Are you do you? No, these guys know that I that I bug I use fight camp. Yeah, so they're gonna both roll the rice This will get cut too. I just this is not gonna get Received my new fight camp yesterday the big box came yes now do I have to blow that thing up? No, no, no The bag will come later. That's just the base and the in the trackers and stuff So anyway, so that's hard enough as a guy as a couple of middle-aged white guys who are boxing in their basements in Beverly Hills
他在我的草稿里会说话。现在他是哑巴，就像我们改变了很多关于它的东西，使它在这个世界上非常独特。嗯，跟我谈谈综合格斗的事，你必须为此训练，那是什么感觉？哦，天哪。你们关注综合格斗吗？你们关注吗？不，这些人知道我……我使用格斗营。是的，所以他们都会……这也会被剪掉。我只是……这不会被……昨天收到了我的新格斗营，大箱子到了，是的。现在我必须把它吹起来吗？不，不，不。袋子稍后会来。那只是底座和追踪器之类的东西。所以无论如何，这作为一个男人，作为一对在比佛利山庄地下室打拳的中年白人来说已经够难了。
Tell us about actually be doing MMA which is real, you know, well, it was hard for a middle-aged black woman Trust me. Yeah, it was I worked harder than I've ever worked on anything. I probably trained on it three years ago I started before I started shooting. I started the training knowing that this was Potentially coming if I could raise the money, but I was you know getting prepared in case I was able to do that so and it was learning like jujitsu and Taekwondo Muay Thai Wrestling kickboxing, you know all these disciplines that I I knew a little bit of capoeira from Catwoman, but you heard anything break anything
告诉我们关于实际做综合格斗的事，那是真实的，你知道，嗯，这对于一个中年黑人女性来说很难。相信我。是的，确实。我比我做过的任何事情都努力。我可能在三年前就开始训练了。我在开始拍摄之前就开始了。我开始训练，知道如果我能筹到钱，这可能会发生，但我，你知道，在做准备，以防我能做到。所以它是学习像柔术、跆拳道、泰拳、摔跤、踢拳，你知道所有这些学科，我从《猫女》中知道一点卡波耶拉，但你听到什么断了吗？
Yeah, did you get did you get hit in the face? Accidentally more often than you accidentally hit somebody in the face. What which is a higher number? I got hit more really. Yeah, so when you get hit in the nose, it really hurts It really does it really does what did you break? I I broke I broke Well, I broke two toes in in training. I dislocated a finger No, and I Day two of shooting, you know, we did the fight first because we were Valentina Chevchenko. She plays my opponent She's the UFC flyweight champion of the world right now. She was my opponent
是的，你的脸被打了吗？意外被打到的次数比你意外打到别人的次数多。哪个数字更高？我被打得更多。真的。是的，所以当你鼻子被打到时，真的很疼。真的，真的。你断了什么？我……我断了……嗯，我断了两根脚趾，在训练中。我脱臼了一根手指。不，我在拍摄的第二天，你知道，我们先拍了打斗戏，因为我们有瓦伦蒂娜·舍甫琴科。她扮演我的对手。她是现在的UFC蝇量级世界冠军。她是我的对手。
So we trained within an inch of our life for like two months heavy like five six hours a day before we actually started to shoot And I shot my fight first as we were ready and it was in our minds our choreo and everything Day two of a five-day fight. I broke two ribs. Oh I know and I knew they were broken But I also knew that if I told anybody they would shut me down, right? so it's hard to breathe and You're like a professional athlete. You're like, no, I got to stay on the field coach That's kind of how I felt and these fighters that talk to me about when they get injured in the cage in the ring
所以我们在真正开始拍摄之前，像两个月一样，每天五六个小时，拼命地训练。我先拍了我的打斗戏，因为我们准备好了，它在我们的脑海里，我们的编舞和一切。五天打斗戏的第二天。我断了两根肋骨。哦，我知道，我知道它们断了。但我也知道，如果我告诉任何人，他们会让我停下来，对吧？所以呼吸很困难。你就像一个职业运动员，你就像，不，我得留在场上，教练。我就是那种感觉，这些拳手跟我谈论他们在笼子里、在拳击台上受伤时。
Like there is no stopping unless the referee or somebody stops it But their mindset is to just keep going you've trained so hard to get to this moment Like you just aren't gonna bail out and that's very much how I felt at the end of that second day I went to my my one of my producers and I said, you know, I I know I broke two ribs But I I I don't know what to do I can't stop and they and you know my he said to me well, you don't want to puncture a lung though I mean, this is kind of dangerous and I said, I know but I've come too far I've worked too hard like this might all go away and never come back and so you so how did you work around that?
就像除非裁判或某人阻止，否则没有停止。但他们的心态就是继续前进。你为了这一刻训练得如此努力，就像你只是不会放弃。这就是我在第二天结束时的感觉。我去找我的一个制片人，我说，你知道，我……我知道我断了两根肋骨，但我……我不知道该怎么办。我不能停下来。他们，你知道，他对我说了，嗯，你不想刺穿肺部。我的意思是，这有点危险。我说，我知道，但我走得太远了，我工作得太努力了，就像这一切可能会消失，再也不会回来。所以你……所以你是怎么解决这个问题的？
How did you get the other three-day shot? Took a lot of Advil. Yeah. Wow. Wow and just prayed that I wouldn't severely injure myself Sean you threw your shoulder, but do you dislocate your shoulder one time? I heat Sean told me they went to Gelson's they switched they put the vanilla wafers on the top shop And he had to reach to get those, you know vanilla wafers Nilla and he and they moved it and Scottie said don't do it and he knew if I tell Scottie that I That I dislocated my shoulder He'll say just get the Graham crackers instead and he was like those Nilla wakers
你是怎么拍完剩下的三天的？吃了很多止痛药。是的。哇。哇，只是祈祷我不会严重伤害自己。肖恩，你拉伤了肩膀，但你有没有一次脱臼肩膀？我……肖恩告诉我他们去了Gelson's，他们换了，他们把香草威化饼放在了顶层货架上。他不得不伸手去拿那些，你知道香草威化饼，Nilla。他，他们移动了它，斯科蒂说别做。他知道如果我告诉斯科蒂我……我脱臼了肩膀，他会说，那就拿全麦饼干吧。他就像，那些Nilla威化饼。
That's right. I said I'm out for those reasons. I'm out. I can't I gotta say that's super admirable Haley, did you did you finally so you it's all this like incredible physical training, but did you get that kind of did you Did you start to get it like a the byproduct of it the happy brought byproduct being that you got a lot of like Mental calmness from it. Did you find it at all sort of? Meditative once you started training a lot and getting into that zone. Did you in any way? I think so, you know so much of the fight game is all mental preparation. I think people focus on you know That chokes and the knockouts and all of that stuff, but really it's a mental game and I my mental game did get strengthened And it's so strong that I think that's the only reason I made it through this film because there was one catastrophe
没错。我说，因为这些原因我退出了。我退出了。我不得不说这非常令人钦佩，哈莉，你最终……所以你经历了所有这些令人难以置信的身体训练，但你得到了那种……你开始得到它了吗？它的副产品，快乐的副产品是，你从中得到了很多心理上的平静。你发现它在某种程度上是冥想性的吗？一旦你开始大量训练并进入那个区域。你以任何方式吗？我想是的，你知道，格斗比赛中很大一部分是心理准备。我认为人们关注，你知道，锁喉和击倒以及所有这些东西，但实际上这是一场心理游戏。我的心理游戏确实得到了加强。它如此强大，以至于我认为这是我能拍完这部电影的唯一原因，因为有一场灾难。
After another when you're trying to make I mean getting any movie made today, you know, it's not easy But an independent low-budget film in the way in which we were making and we were losing money left and right that mental Fortitude that came from those three years of training and what I learned definitely I'll have that I'll have that with me for the rest of my life and I'll keep training. What about the directing part was it? Did you would you would you jump to it again? Or did you did you find yourself longing for the? the the simplicity of Hanging out in your trailer and waiting for them to get it all sorted out and then come get you and time to talk I Don't think so. You know what it made me feel Jason is I really don't want to be only the dancing bear anymore
接踵而至，当你试图制作……我的意思是，今天制作任何电影，你知道，都不容易。但以我们制作的那种低成本独立电影，我们一直在赔钱，那种从那三年训练中获得的心理坚韧，以及我学到的东西，我肯定会带着它度过余生，我会继续训练。导演部分呢？你会再次尝试吗？还是你发现自己渴望那种在拖车里闲逛，等待他们把一切都整理好，然后来找你，有时间谈话的简单？我不这么认为。你知道这让我感觉到了什么，杰森，我真的不想再只做跳舞的熊了。
Yeah, you know, yeah, well, you know too much. You've had all that said experience. It's just like why waste it Yeah, and I now know through this experience that I can do it You know that I can do it and I probably won't do it I won't star in and you know direct again like I did this like that was just too hard And I and I don't want to do that again, but directing and you say that now you say that now mm-hmm No, you're gonna you're gonna see no It's it's too I think either one of both of those jobs are largely enough You know that and I really would want to focus solely on either one of those jobs
是的，你知道，嗯，你知道得太多了。你有了所有那些经验。这就像，为什么要浪费它？是的，我现在通过这次经历知道我可以做到。你知道我可以做到。我可能不会再做……我不会再像那样主演并导演了，就像那太难了，我不想再那样做了。但导演，你现在这么说，你现在这么说，嗯。不，你会……你会看到。不，它太……我认为这两份工作中的任何一份都足够了。你知道，我真的想专注于这两份工作中的任何一份。
Like that's the kind of artist until you're directing a film and you've got some actress that you've hired that is just not as Cooperative as you want. Oh, if I was playing this part, I would agree with everything I'm sorry. I know and it would be much more efficient. Yeah. Hey dancing bear. Would you ever I mean dancing bear Shawn? Would you? That's all I don't mean anybody's a dancing bear. I am I do we are kind of dancing bears. We are I'm married to a bear and I am a dancer. So listen, and I'm about to go be a dancing bear in two months Really? Where are you going? You gonna join in the circus? I am I'm going back to the circus I'm gonna be a dancing bear again, and there's value in being the dancing bear So what I meant when I said that because I don't want to offend anybody
就像那是那种艺术家，直到你导演一部电影，你雇佣了一些女演员，她不像你希望的那样合作。哦，如果我在演这个角色，我会同意一切。对不起。我知道，那会更有效率。是的。嘿，跳舞的熊，你会吗？我的意思是，跳舞的熊肖恩，你会吗？这就是全部，我不是说任何人是跳舞的熊。我……我们确实有点像跳舞的熊。我们是。我嫁给了一只熊，我是一个舞者。所以听着，我两个月后就要去当跳舞的熊了。真的？你要去哪？你要加入马戏团吗？我是，我要回到马戏团。我要再次成为跳舞的熊，当跳舞的熊是有价值的。所以我说那话时是什么意思，因为我不想冒犯任何人。
It's just once you you know step into a new power and you realize that you can actually be a part of telling the story and has A woman through your lens with your gaze like that feels really Enriching and empowering because we're so long as women our stories have been told through the gaze of men Right and and I can't honestly tell you that I feel it's always been Accurate because it's from a different lens and we've had to fight to have our stories told through our lens when You know men are at the helm and men are directing and as a woman It was so nice to just not have to fight for my point of view But because I was in control of it and I got to just do it that felt really empowering. Do you I love that do you?
这只是，一旦你，你知道，步入一种新的力量，你意识到你实际上可以成为讲述故事的一部分，并且作为一个女人，通过你的镜头，用你的目光，那感觉真的很丰富和赋权，因为我们作为女性，我们的故事被男人的目光讲述了太久了。对吧，我不能诚实地告诉你，我觉得它一直很准确，因为它是从不同的镜头来看的，我们不得不奋斗，让我们的故事通过我们的镜头来讲述，当你知道男人在掌舵，男人在导演时。作为一个女人，不用为我的观点而奋斗真是太好了。但因为我控制了它，我只是做到了，那感觉真的很赋权。你……我喜欢那个，你……
Did you still after your MMA? Experience take some of that now that you're done and you still go back and train and stuff like that Did you carry any that with you? You're like, you know what that was I'm done with that I can just go to the gym like a normal person and work out. No, I'm you know, I'm addicted you you start rolling Yeah, they call it rolling. You did see you start rolling. You just just something you you you don't want to give up So do you watch this fight? I'd love to see you beat Jason up I bet she could beat my ass anything to watch you beat up baby. Oh, yeah, I'm like a veal It's just easy pickings. Yeah
你在综合格斗之后，还保留了一些吗？现在你完成了，你还回去训练之类的吗？你带着它了吗？你就像，你知道吗，那是……我受够了。我可以像正常人一样去健身房锻炼。不，你知道，我上瘾了。你开始滚动。是的，他们称之为滚动。你确实看到了，你开始滚动。你只是……只是有些东西你不想放弃。所以你每周都看那些比赛吗？哦，天哪，是的。我给瓦伦蒂娜发短信，我说，我喜欢它。你知道，我和瓦伦蒂娜以及这项运动中的许多女性变得非常非常亲密，这是……这是我的热情。太棒了。是的，太棒了。它什么时候出来？嗯，11月17日在影院上映，但在感恩节周末11月24日在Netflix上。我太兴奋了。我迫不及待想看它。太酷了。我为它感到兴奋。而且你……所以你并没有急于回到导演椅上，但你不反对它。是的，杰森想给你发个剧本。你想发吗？是的。
So you are you watching those fights every week? Oh my god, yeah I'm texting data and I'm like, I love it You know, I've become really really tight with Valentina and so many of the women of the sport and it's it's it's my passion That's great. Yeah, that's great. When does it come out? Um in theaters on November 17th, but on Netflix Thanksgiving Day weekend November 24. I'm so excited. I can't wait to see it So cool. I'm so excited for it And you're and so you're not chomping at the bit to get back in the director's chair, but you were not opposed to it Yeah, Jason wants to send you a script. You want to send? Yeah
是的，我急不可耐，我确实想做。我知道我不会主演它。但我……但我也知道，因为这次经历，它必须是我喜欢的东西，你知道，我想找到另一个我可以重新构思、可以塑造的故事。因为我真的意识到我必须看到它。我必须感觉到它。我们花了很多时间，我花了我生命中的三年做那个。所以我知道它必须是能打动我的东西，能让我感到受启发的东西，有一个故事，有一个讲述对我来说很重要的故事的理由，你知道，所以我必须找到那个东西。我不认为我能成为一个受雇的导演。
Yeah, I'm chomping like I do want to do it. I know I won't start it But I but I also know because of this experience It has to be something that I love, you know, I want to find another story that I can reimagine that I can shape Because I really realize I have to see it. I have to feel it. We spend so much time I spent three years of my life doing that So I know that it has to be something that moves me that makes me feel inspired that there's a story There's a reason to tell the story that matters to me, you know, so I have to find that thing I don't think I could ever be a director for hire
我必须……我必须找到那个再次点燃我的东西，对吧。这说得通。我有个主意。这是一个……我要发给你，哈莉，是关于一个男人的。他太帅了，不能上播客，但他被困在那里了。我很忙。我告诉过你我很忙。你太忙了，所以你……所以如果你不想做那个，而且你……我的意思是，你有点……我想你可以……你只是在做很多不同的事情。你五年后觉得自己会在哪里？你会那样想吗？比如我想做这个，或者我想完成这个。你提前计划这些事情吗？并不是真的，而且你知道，我觉得有时我们可以设定那种目标，但我们可能会达不到。
I have to I have to find that thing that ignites me like that right again. That makes sense I've got an idea. It's a that I'm gonna send you how it's about a guy. He's too handsome to be on a podcast But he's stuck there. I'm busy. I told you I'm busy You're so busy so what do you so so if you don't want to do that and you I mean you kind of I guess you can you You're just doing so many different things. Where do you see yourself like five years from now? Do you do you think like that? Like I want to do this or I want to get this done Do you plan stuff out in advance like that? Not really and you know, I I feel like sometimes we can set those kind of goals and we can fall short
你知道，我们可以限制自己，比如我从没想过我会导演。那从来不是一个真正的目标，有一天我会导演。我……有时意识到，你知道，你被召唤去做事情，你被召唤去实现你的目标。我……我们开头谈到的那个东西，你的命运。所以我感觉我……我不喜欢有大的大的计划，因为我觉得它可能会有限制性。我对午餐也有这种感觉。是的。是的，我尽量不去想午餐要吃什么。我只是有点像……跟着我的胃走。你尽量不去想你要吃什么，但……不可能不去想吃午餐，对吧？就像那是一个常数。是的，那是真的。那是……那是伟大的。那是正确的语境。哦。
You know, we can limit ourselves with like I never thought I would be directing That was never a real goal that one day I'm gonna direct. I I Realize it sometimes, you know, you get called to do things and you get called to realize your purpose and I that thing we talked about in the beginning your destiny. So I feel like I Don't like to have big big plans because I think it could be limiting. I feel that way about lunch. Yeah Yeah, I try not to think too hard about what I'm gonna eat for lunch. I just kind of like go where my stomach You try not to think about what you're gonna eat, but but it's impossible not to think about eating for right lunch Like that's a constant. Yeah, that's true. That's it. That's the great. That's the right context. Oh
哦，天哪，我知道。嗯，哈莉，我们占用了你太多时间了。你太亲切了，非常感谢。一直以来都是你的粉丝。你一直是一个非常……你知道，很好的人，只是跟你打个招呼，但我真的是你的粉丝。我从来没能真正说出来。而且每次我见到你，这些年来并不多，你总是那么友善和热情。我只想和你一起待上几个小时。你就像，我……更多，更多哈莉。是的。谢谢你们。我非常感谢你们。我喜欢你们正在做的事情。你们真好。
Oh my god, I know Well, Halle, we've taken away too much of your time. I you're so gracious and thank you so much Just always been such a fan. You've always been very You know nice person to just say hi to you and but I'm just such a fan of you I've never been able to actually say that so And every single time I've seen you which isn't a lot over the years You've always been so kind and welcoming. I just want to hang out with you for hours. You're like I'm more more Halle. Yeah. Thank you guys. I appreciate you so much. I love what you're doing. Very nice of you
谢谢。非常感谢。谢谢你加入我们，祝电影大获成功，我们会再和你谈谈。谢谢你的到来。谢谢。谢谢。再见，伙计们。再见。再见。嗯，那是一次美妙的……美妙的收获。我像我说的那样，我见过她很多次，我们……我总是……上次见到她是在一个筹款活动上，我走过去，就在她旁边坐下。我们进行了最棒的谈话。她就是那么开放，而且她非常开放，顺便说一句，你那样说的方式，因为你的措辞太糟糕了，我以为你说的是筹款活动，这是一个好主意。就像你只是举办一个筹款活动，你只是要筹集一些乐趣，对吧？
Thank you. Thank you so much. Thanks for joining us and so much success with the film and we'll talk to you again Thanks for coming. Thank you. Thanks. Bye you guys. Bye. Bye Well, that was a wonderful Wonderful get I like I said, I've met her many times and we I always like last time I saw her was at a Fundraiser event and I went over to her and just sat down next to her. We had the greatest conversation She's just so open and she is so open by the way you the way you said that because your diction is so terrible I thought you said fundraiser, which is a great idea Like you just have a fundraiser where you just gonna raise some fun, right?
你只是走到人们身边，坐在他们旁边。他们根本不知道你是谁。她叫你史蒂夫·斯科特了吗？什么？是的，她和内斯特很亲近。是的，不，她……她是一个……是的，你是对的，她是一个如此善良、真诚的人，而且非常……某种程度上甜美，对她遇到的人慷慨地付出时间，而且她非常外向。是的，她太棒了。然后谁能忘记她赢得那个奥斯卡奖？她赢得了那个奖项，并且为那个角色应得的，真是太巨大了。我记得看那部电影，我只是……被震撼了。我记得她很久以前讲过一个故事，我忘了对她说这个，而且……
And you just walk up on people and sit down next to them. They have no idea who you are Did she call you Steve Scott anything? Yeah, she was close with the nest. Yeah, no, she's she's a yeah, you're right she's such a nice genuine person and Very sort of sweet and generous with her time into people that she meets and she's very outgoing Yeah, she's awesome and then who can forget her winning that Oscar? That was just so huge that she won and deserved for that role. I remember seeing that movie I was just like blown away. I remembered her telling a story a long time ago I forgot to say this to her and
在一些谈话或什么地方，她躺在床上读剧本，她只是……在哭。她说，我必须做那个。我记得她讲过关于读《死囚之舞》剧本的故事。那真的很酷。嗯，我希望我一直纠缠她关于多导演的事，我只是……我想要更多的哈莉·贝瑞，就像我非常兴奋，在她……那个奥斯卡奖前后，她有那么高频率的……你知道，工作。我感觉到她对她选择的事情更加深思熟虑，这当然是令人钦佩的。但这就是为什么我在想，嗯，也许如果她没有……
Some talks or something where she was lying in bed reading the script and she was just like crying She's like, I have to do that. I remember her telling the story about reading the script of monsters ball. It was really cool Well, I hope the reason I was I was badgering her about directing more I just I want more Halle Berry like I was so excited that there was such a high frequency of of her, you know work, you know in and around that that Oscar and I Get the sense. She's being a little bit more deliberate about the things that she's picking which is admirable for sure But that's why I was thinking well, maybe if she's not
找到她作为演员喜欢的角色，她会给我们更多的哈莉·贝瑞。也许通过导演。是的，我开始为自己创造那些机会。你的意思是，你是对的，因为她拍了所有那些巨大的……像《X战警》电影。她拍了一百万部，她拍了一堆大的，你知道，大量的电影。但随后去拍一些更……某种程度上策划的，或者一些，你知道，无论如何，美妙。她太不可思议了。我知道她是最好的。她太棒了，能让她上节目真是太幸运了，而且是一个伟大的名字。你知道，让我们不要……让我们不要……让我们不要掩盖重点。这只是伟大的好莱坞名字之一，哈莉·贝瑞。如果她……因为她有一个英国母亲，你会怎么说她的姓氏？
Finding parts that she likes as an actor that she would give us more Halle Berry. Maybe through directing Yeah, I start creating those opportunities for herself You mean you're right because she's done like all those huge like X-Men movies She made a million of those and she made a bunch of big, you know tons of big movies But then to go and do stuff that's a little more kind of curated or a little, you know, I don't know anyway wonderful She's incredible. I know she's the best. She's so good and so lucky to have had her on the show and a great name You know, let's not let's not let's not bury the lead here. It's just one of the great Hollywood names Halle Berry. How would you say her last name if she because she has a an English mother?
对吧，所以你会怎么说？关于肖恩，事情是这样的。是的，这就像……这就像你不仅能看到它到来？这就像远光灯，远光灯，是的，你能闻到它，远光灯。你有一个烟雾信号，对吧？你可以看到它从……让我试着带着漂亮的秒数说她的姓氏。哈莉·贝瑞。不，那是爱尔兰语，让爱尔兰语……爱尔兰语也行。然后音乐响起。我知道你在你的公寓里，因为否则我会说，把你从后院带出来，然后只是……吃掉我自己的屎。是的，然后用你自己的手淹死自己。把你自己的头按在水下。下周见，听众。
Right, so how would you say? Here's the thing about Sean. Yeah, it's like it's like you can not only can you see it coming? It's like the high beams the high yeah, you can smell it the high beams. You got a smoke signal, right? You can see it coming from Let me just try to do her last name with a pretty second. Halle Berry No, that's Irish make Irish Irish works though and cue the music I know you're in your apartment because otherwise I'd say take you take yourself out of the backyard and just and just eat the Shit on myself. Yeah, and just drown yourself with your own hand. Hold your own head under the water. See you next week listener
再见。哦，哦，哦，等等。哦，就是这样。不，我只是要走老派路线。再见。Smartless是由本内特·巴贝克、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗伯手工制作的100%有机和艺术品。我是杰夫·斯马特。我们的下一集将在下周播出，无论你在哪里听播客，或者你现在就可以听。在亚马逊音乐上提前听，或者通过订阅Apple播客或Wondry应用程序中的Wondry Plus提前且无广告地听。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
Bye. Oh, oh, oh, wait. Oh, that's it. No, I'm just gonna go old school. Bye Smartless is 100% organic and artisan Lee handcrafted by Bennett barbecue Michael Grant Terry and Rob. I'm Jeff Smart Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now Early on Amazon music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple podcasts or the Wondry app There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。噢，噢，噢，等等。噢，就这样。不，我还是用老派的方式吧。再见。Smartless 是百分之百有机的，由 Bennett Barbecue、Michael Grant Terry 和 Rob 手工制作。我是 Jeff Smart。我们的下一集将在下周发布，你可以在任何收听播客的地方收听，或者你现在就可以在 Amazon Music 上抢先收听，也可以通过在 Apple Podcasts 或 Wondry App 上订阅 Wondry Plus 来抢先收听且无广告。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。